[Music]
we have a confession we're totally
obsessed with a loud house today we're
showing you some of our favorite moments
most fans have totally forgot about stay
tuned to find out which moment
completely melted our hearts and made us
fall in love with this show even more
don't forget to hit that notification
bell to never miss another video and be
sure to check out our community section
for even more fun now let's check out
some of the most hilarious loud house
moments you totally forgot about LuAnn
loses her confidence in comedy the loud
house might be just another wacky
nickelodeon show but it actually comes
with a lot of important life lessons
almost every episode comes with a lesson
you can use in your own life but we
really love the season 2 episode 21
called no laughing matter
LuAnn isn't always the focus of the
episodes but she is in this one as the
prankster of the family LuAnn can be
seen as slightly annoying but that
doesn't mean she doesn't totally stop
with the jokes on their shell bones
in that episode we've seen Luanne crank
every single one of her siblings and
since they were pretty over her pranks
they weren't exactly happy Luanne
overheard them saying how annoying she
is with her jokes
of course this hurt Luann's feelings how
could it not it was a heartbreaking
moments that made Luanne completely shut
down the siblings managed to resolve
their differences and by the end of the
episode Luanne was back to her old punny
self we all know her puns are just
amazing anyways this was just one of
those episodes that serves as a reminder
to be nice to people you never know who
will overhear your comments and what
effect that might have on their life
Lincoln things he'll get kicks from the
house speaking of overhearing things how
could we possibly forget about this
moment it comes from one of the episodes
Hardcore allowed house fans have a
love/hate relationship with season 1
episode 9 B is easily one of the most
heartbreaking episodes ever and not a
fun one to watch the story focuses on
Lincoln who overhears their parents
talking about getting rid of a large
collection of ties of course Lincoln
doesn't cure the tie part and things
they actually mean they're getting rid
of one of the loud kids the situation is
even worse when Lincoln later overhears
that his dad has decided to get rid of
the one with the white hair he meant
hair as in the rabbits but Lincoln
clearly thought he was talking about him
he does have white hair after all
completely heartbroken Lincoln actually
things that his parents are actually
going to get rid of him how terrible is
that that's pretty traumatic for any
child to experience of course everything
ends up being resolved and Lincoln does
find out that his parents were actually
talking about ties but this is one of
those moments where our hearts
collectively broke for Lincoln Lincoln
actually getting kicked out and it
wasn't the only moment that made our
hearts break let's be honest Lincoln has
to go through a lot as the only boy in
such a large family it's something
that's often criticized by fans who just
can't understand why his sisters pick on
him so much Lincoln always tends to help
everyone but he doesn't always get the
same back it's the middle child curse
isn't it it's but in the no such luck
episode
and pretty much gets kicked out of any
family activities
seriously they might as well kick him
out of the house and the reason was that
he was seen as bad luck
it all started with Lynn losing her game
when Lincoln was there and it quickly
spread to the rest of the family at some
point Lincoln is pretty much removed
from all family events and he even has
to sleep outside and it was all because
Lincoln played along with the fact that
Lynne thought he was bad luck poor
Lincoln he has to go through so much
drama as with every loud episode
everything eventually gets resolved but
it's just one of those moments even fans
don't really want to rewatch when Ronnie
n left
Ronnie Ann is definitely one of the most
interesting characters on the show
outside of the loud family were first
introduced to her as Lincoln's class
bullies but it actually turns out that
she has a bit of a crush on Lincoln
we're still not exactly sold on that
life lesson from Nickelodeon but that's
not the point here
in season two episode 13 we're
introduced to Ronnie Anne's family we
really know Bobby who's actually
Laurie's boyfriend but we have no idea
about the other members of the
Casagrande family
it was completely heartbreaking scene
Ronnie Ann gets so sad about leaving but
one of the reasons why you should always
remember this episode is because it
leads to something else
it's actually an introduction episode
the loud house spin-off show it's
focusing on Ronnie Ann and her family
and their adjustments to the big city
life Nickelodeon ordered 20 episodes so
we'll be getting plenty of more fun from
Ronnie M so if you totally forgot about
season 2 episode 13 you should rewatch
it because it'll lead to the spin-off
just make sure that you don't watch it
if you're in the process of moving house
yourself when Lisa got to work at an
institute we all know Lisa is wise
beyond her years
well she has to be considering she's
only four years old
come on Lincoln no one in this family
ever willingly lets me do experiments on
Nana we don't get to see a lot of
special moments like this on the loud
house but this is one that was
definitely a highlight
remember when Lisa got to actually study
at a Science Institute in season three
what four year old gets to do that
this particular episode is called the
mad scientist and did we just love that
all the focus gets to be on Lisa she
actually breaks into song at some point
and she gets to explain Einstein's
theory of time-travel the biggest lol
moment comes when she video calls her
family and tells them she'd like to stay
at the Institute she explains that her
passion for science stands at about 97
percent and the emotional attachment to
her family is just at 1 percent to be
honest we see it this is Lisa we're
talking about after all if you're the
independence one in your family you know
exactly what Lisa was feeling when she
tried to convince her parents to stay at
the Institute of course later on Lisa's
emotional attachment levels changed but
this was absolutely hilarious to see we
love seeing Lisa so passionate about
science when Lenny made everyone eat old
sandwiches drift is the very first
episode of season 3 so naturally people
had high expectations when it came out
but luckily for the creators of the show
it was actually a pretty hilarious
episode one of the best moments comes
from the roadtrip lunchtime we all know
Lenny isn't exactly the brightest of the
bunch but she makes things absolutely
hilarious so when lunch time came the
family decided to eat Lenny sandwiches
of course they all got pretty sick
Lenny then revealed that her sandwiches
were weeks old and we know why because
she planned ahead of time and made these
sandwiches weeks before they even went
on the trip Oh Lenny this started the
downhill of the entire vacation but it's
by far one of the most hilarious
episodes
lesson learned never plan your
sandwiches that much in advance because
they'll get spoiled we don't even want
to know exactly how old Lenny sandwiches
were but by the looks of it they sound
pretty gross seriously just don't play
in eating the sandwich weeks in advance
their best when they're eaten fresh when
the loud sisters acted like they don't
have her brother we already said that
Lincoln goes through a lot in this house
right well fans have pointed out several
episodes in which they think Lincoln's
being
totally unfairly in season one episode
to be called making the case blinken
showed us what it's like to live in a
large family in this episode we see
Lincoln filming funny things whose
sisters did and uploading the videos to
the Internet obviously he doesn't let
his sister's know which is a huge no-no
this was definitely wrong on his part
all of his sisters immediately got angry
and even though he explained his
reasoning for it they didn't really
forgive him they were so furious they
ended up completely disowning him and
for the rest of the time they pretty
much pretended they have no brother
Lincoln did try to apologize but of
course nobody really listened to him
although Lincoln definitely made a
mistake especially since his videos were
extremely humiliating we want to know
what you think did he deserve this
treatment from his sisters it's not like
they really really liked him in other
episodes he always seems to get into
some kind of trouble
when Lauri tried to make Bobby jealous
season 1 is just full of amazing moments
but one of the most hilarious ones comes
from an episode called affair to
remember in this episode we see Bobby
and Lincoln become best Bros to the
points where Bobby starts kind of
neglecting Laurie of course
Laurie isn't happy about that and she
tries to get back at him she knows Clyde
is madly in love with her so she invites
him to take him to the fair where Bobby
and Lincoln are hanging out Clyde is
clearly passed out because he just can't
believe he got a date with Laurie but
Laurie still drags him around
Laurie even flirts with him at some
point just to make Bobby jealous of
course this isn't how you should deal
with problems in your relationships but
we just feel for Clyde because he
finally got his dream come true but he
missed it because he basically passed
out poor Clyde it's also kind of cute
how Lincoln doesn't want to lose the
friendship he has with Bobby especially
since he doesn't really have a lot of
male role models in his life seriously
this is one episode you have to re-watch
when Lin said there were not enough
balls in Lincoln's room Nickelodeon is
known for its subtle inappropriate jokes
that often go over kids heads but we
promise you that a parent has definitely
raised an eyebrow and watching the loud
house one such episode
from season 1 episode 6 be called space
invader we've covered this episode a lot
in other videos but we feel like people
totally forgot about this moment Lin and
Lucy don't always get along and in this
episode they end up having a fight
they're complete polar opposites so it's
natural they sometimes don't get along
Lin doesn't really want to sleep in
Lucy's room so she asks Lincoln if she
can stay there but Lin has 0 boundaries
whatsoever she plays with his toys and
is quite rude despite the fact that
Lincoln told her to not touch anything
but the most eyebrow raising moment
comes when she brings in sports balls
and tells Lincoln that his room has a
lack of balls the pause after definitely
indicated that this was an innuendo it
gets even more suspicious because this
comedic pause was completely removed
from the UK episode I'm noticing a
complete lack of balls in this room
Lincoln definitely couldn't deal with
Lin during that episode and it was
hilarious to see Lunas crush L is for
love is the 12 B episode of season 2 and
it's one of our favorite ones sure the
episode actually got banned in Russia
and Malaysia because of their views on
the lgbtq+ community but we think it's
absolutely adorable the way the
creator's decided to tell the story of
Lunas crush of course we think people
should be more concerned at the fact
that the kids went to meet a stranger at
a restaurant but the most adorable
moment that people totally forgot about
comes from the very end it all starts
with a love letter that's addressed to a
certain L loud this is totally useless
because all of the loud kids have names
that start with the letter L the kids
try to find out who this letter is
addressed to and it turns out it is
their parents at the end of the episode
they each single letter to their own
crush but Luna is the most nervous one
to do that she does end up leaving her
letter in her crushes locker room that's
where we find out that she has a crush
on a girl called Sam how adorable it's
by far one of our favorite moments ever
what's your favorite but underrated
moment of the loud house come let us
know in the comments and that's it for
our video
forget to subscribe to the things for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]